io vi racconto di due cose nella mia
esperienza di sviluppo di territori di
città vi racconta dei virus che ho
trovato e vi racconto di alcune
possibili vitamine che si possono
iniettare all'interno di questi
territori
partiamo dalle dai virus
mia mamma è cresciuta con l'idea che
l'economia si fa coi soldi io ho
studiato economia non l'ho ancora
convinta che l'economia non si faccia
con i soldi ma se guardate lo sviluppo
dei territori
la cosa più deleteria che è accaduto nel
panorama italiano ma non solo è che dove
sono arrivati i soldi non si è creato
sviluppo
facciamo degli esempi basilicata io ho
parlato con molti sindaci della
basilicata
ci hanno detto non ci siamo accorti che
in 15 anni ci hanno riempito di
royalties petrolifere sono arrivati una
marea di soldi non abbiamo creato
sviluppo
facciamo un altro esempio vengo dall
area terremotata piceno fermana quindi
soprattutto nel piceno lo sviluppo si è
creato il lavoro scusate sia creato
perché alcune multinazionali sono venute
e hanno investito queste multinazionali
sono andate via e lo sviluppo non si è
creata risorse finanziarie sono arrivate
ma lo sviluppo non si è creata fondi
strutturali europei alcuni di voi ne
hanno sentito parlare andate a leggere i
rapporti su come sono stati spesi i
fondi europei nelle precedenti
programmazioni che tipo di impatto ha
creato sui territori in italia forse
peggio che in altri ma non in tutti i
territori allora qua c'è un rischio che
molti territori con la scusa di dire non
abbiamo i soldi non abbiamo i soldi sono
diventati poveri di idee e allora da
questo punto di vista la prima domanda è
come si sviluppa un territorio oggi come
si promuove ieri abbiamo parlato molto
di promozione la promozione non è
vi racconto un territorio promuovere
significa farlo muovere un territorio
farlo progredire provocarlo seconda
questione prendo spunto una riflessione
che ha fatti ilvio diamanti nel nei
giorni scorsi e dice guardate
soprattutto in questa italia di mezzo
quelli toscana io sono marchigiano
marche in questa italia e mezzo c'è
stato in passato uno spazio economico
sociale civile molto virtuoso si è
creato molto sviluppo in questi
territori
ora il rischio che questa italia di
mezzo si sia trasformata in un italia
media cioè che le virtù di questi
territori abbiano perso una t e siano
diventate quasi dei virus si siano
sbiadite le virtù che hanno portato
questi territori
lahti che si è persa è l'ati di
territorio
questi territori sono sviluppati perché
avevano un legame forte con il
territorio
pian piano il rischio è che si è
sgretolato ilvo diamanti dice siamo di
fronte a un contesto locale fatta di
eredità familiari dove fiorivano le
relazioni
oggi le associazioni si stanno perdendo
così come le relazioni i giovani non ci
sono più se ne stanno andando il calo
demografico evidenti dobbiamo
preoccuparci di un'italia senza colore
senza radici perché perdendo il passato
perdiamo anche il futuro allora la
seconda domanda è i virus riconosciamo
ma quali possono essere le vitamine di
questi territori
ora io nella mia umiltà e poca
esperienza avendo 35 anni
ho selezionato tre vitamine secondo me
interessanti per accompagnare i
territori la prima è quella che mi sta
più a cuore
ancorché meno concreta però attenzione
bisogna ripensare alle retoriche del
territorio
quando si va in giro si incontrano delle
retoriche del territorio che sono più
estensioni inerziali del passato e
nostalgiche piuttosto che forze motrici
dello sviluppo futuro
l'idea che i territori debbano
continuare ad essere quello che sono
stati per 30 40 anni non è convincente
non è
non guarda a un modo di progredire
vi faccio solo un esempio che facevo
anche ieri non è possibile che tutti i
territori che hanno avuto un ruolo in
passato vedono nel futuro turismo e
cultura turismo e cultura si ma dentro
un contesto di produzione di turismo di
cultura
in che modo un territorio si rivede in
un contesto di nuova produzione in che
modo un territorio non si pensa solo
come attrattore dei consumatori ma come
attrattore di nuovi produttori che sono
in grado di dire mettere in relazione
conoscenza servizi innovativi
innovazione e portarla fuori produzione
significa portar fuori
questa è la prima vitamina quindi e
tanti creativi comunicatori che ho
incontrato devono aiutarci a ripensare
questa retorica seconda siamo cresciuti
con una idea che con il capitale umano è
un po di capitale sociale
ce la si faceva capitale umano vuol dire
gente capace intendere di volere
istruita capitale sociale un po di
spirito di servizio civico volontariato
credo che non basti più siamo in una
società piena di solventi dove se non
ricreiamo un nuovo capitale che non è né
quell'umano né quello sociale ma il
capitale di connessione il rischio che
la società e l'economia sia sempre più
stride sfibrata e le nuove economie non
siamo in grado di intercettare
io sono cresciuto con il detto che mi
diceva mia mamma chi fa da sé fa per tre
questa generazione è cresciuta con
questo detto qua le nuove economie
i relatori precedenti ce l'hanno
raccontato questo detto non lo possono
che applica questa data non possono
intercettare le nuove economie che sono
basate nella capacità di produrre
insieme beni collettivi nel produrre
insieme qualità sociale allora da questo
punto di vista la domanda diventa in che
modo un territorio l'este le sue
istituzioni non si aprono solo i dati ma
si aprono anche ai processi e diventano
collanti per collaborare per migliorare
questo capitale di connessione in che
modo sindacati
le categorie comuni non diventino solo
portatori di propri interessi ma
collanti di una comunità che produce
beni collettivi terza vitamina io sono
nato nel distretto calzaturiero fermano
so benissimo che l'abbiamo sfangata
perché c'è stata la genialità dei
piccoli dei singoli che si sono messi in
autonomia e hanno creato impresa ecco
questa logica come dell'individualità
produttiva e dell'essere anche un po
padroni del proprio tempo
credo che sia un po finite bisogna
abbracciare una logica di intrapresa
collettiva nella necessità di una logica
un po più orientate alla cooperazione e
al riconoscimento reciproco
è come se fossimo entrati in una logica
di coralità produttiva che pochi di noi
hanno conosciuto ma che sicuramente sarà
lo sfondo dentro cui dovremmo dovremo
rischiare un po di più allora queste
sono tre vitamine che la dicono lunga
sul fatto che probabilmente servono
anche meno euro di quello che pensiamo
poi gli euro servono un po mia mamma
ragione servono meno rara di quelli che
pensiamo e serve un po più di coscienza
di luogo la chiama becattini l'inventore
del dis dei distretti industriali ci
dice che l'economia non è l'input
dell'economia è diventata la coscienza
dell'uomo per un investitore che mette
un euro su un territorio e tante più
importante capire se quel territorio ha
un grado di coscienza elevato oppure no
probabilmente a lipparini dovremmo dare
l'assessorato alla coscienza oltre che
la partecipazione questo potrebbe essere
una nuova provocazione per le città
perché la partecipazione è un concetto
che che va bene però come diceva
pedreschi per passare dai dati alla
conoscenza per passare dalla
partecipazione alla coscienza servono
anche strumenti diversi servono anche
collanti diversi allora siamo entrati in
un mondo un po di capovolgimenti me ne
rendo conto
silvano petrosino che un filosofo c'è
scritto anche un libro su questi
capovolgimenti lui ne ha indicati alcuni
la casa non è una tana
perché l'appartamento no era il luogo
dove ci si appartava adesso non è più un
luogo dove ci si apparta ma si esce
l'economia non è il business
però ci sono altri capovolgimenti che
noi stiamo riscoprendo nello sviluppo
dei territori
il capovolgimento del tema della
promozione che vi dicevo prima ma anche
del tema della comunicazione
noi tutti ci sembra che comunicare siano
non trasferire e comunicare la radice
significa mettere in comune allora
quanto dei dati che vediamo sono messi
davvero in comune in una logica di
creazione di conoscenze un altro
capovolgimento e che la qualità delle
decisioni non dipende solo da che tipo
di democrazia siamo ma dipende molto
dalla qualità delle relazioni che noi
costruiamo e un altro capovolgimento che
l'ultimo è che fare economia oggi non
significa solo metterci un euro
quando io vedo i rapporti che indicano
che un euro messo in cultura ne creano 4
mi dico va bene saranno fatti bene anche
i conti ma chissenefrega
qual è il tema qual è il vero
moltiplicatore di investimento di un
territorio
gli posso creare 4 euro e morire
domattina oppure posso investire un euro
creare un circuito di competenze
conoscenze capacità di co design del
territorio e creare sviluppo allora da
questo punto di vista ci vorremmo un po
tutti abituare in questi capovolgimenti
e io vado a casa cercando di convincerla
mia mamma che l'economia si può fare
anche senza salvi grazie
[Applauso]